welcome back to las vegas now if you're
looking for a
unique gift to give this holiday season
we want to introduce you to alex ross
a line of hand-painted wearable art
check it out
i've been drawing kitties because i love
kitties
um i have two cats myself and i started
drawing those
probably about 25 years ago
these characters have come alive to me
because in my imagination when i'm
drawing them
i have a whole storyline and each one
has a personality
my favorite of course is lucy because
she's my puppy
but i really like uh fergus um
and he's the food critic our food critic
and i love brutus because he's grouchy
brutus is one of my favorite characters
because he was born on the wrong side of
the tracks
and every morning he gets up on the
wrong side of the bed
and he wanted to get a job so he went
down to the local five and dime
and got a job in the complaint
department
well soon everyone was complaining about
brutus because he had such
a bad attitude and he was such a grouse
grouch that he was sending customers
away
so they had to close down that
department i just all her characters
have personality
and and the story she wrote fit them so
perfectly
so it's just the whole thing is fun it's
my most fun job i've ever had
well i have we have 23 aprons right now
so i've got 23 stories and i've got more
coming
i called her last summer and
when she did the mural on my wall and
asked her if she would start drawing
specifically as a business for us for
aprons and
and purses and so that's what she
started doing and we focused all her
work on that
well we decided aprons because
we wanted it big we wanted the artwork
work big
and they show up great against the white
and people are cooking
more nowadays because they're staying in
their homes
and so we thought it would be a really
fun way for
people to get into cooking our aprons
are
really well priced and they make great
gifts and
anybody who sees them loves them so
they're they're perfect for christmas
and the masks are of course because
everybody has to wear a mask now
and it's more fun to wear something that
is
cute over your face than something
that's not cute
we have a website called alex ross.world
so go there and you can see all of our
aprons all of our adult and children's
masks we also have greeting cards
and wall art as well
give alex ross world a call at
all 833-781-5222 until december
fifteenth and each apron order comes
with a free matching adult mask and a
character story card